[Musique]
des géants des lumignons sommes en plein
coeur de la campagne cantabrique ici
c'est harvey a accru toucher du doigt
aux rêves produire de l'électricité
propre en s'assurant un complément de
revenu un visage soccer et chaque est ce
que vous voyez ici c'est mon parc
solaire
il devait être ma source d'énergie il a
été la source de tous mes ennuis
en 2007 césar dépense 1 million d'euros
dans ses six panneaux solaires à
l'époque le gouvernement socialiste
encourage les citoyens à investir dans
le photovoltaïque en échange d'une
promesse leur fournir une aide à
l'investissement et la garantie d'un
prix d'achat fixe de l'énergie produite
tard à la motion mon investissement
devait être rentabilisé au bout de
quinze ans après je devais commencer à
gagner de l'argent alors j'ai réfléchi
et je me suis dit que ce serait une
bonne source de revenus pour payer les
études de monfils dans le cas où il
voudrait partir à l'étranger
mais trois ans plus tard le ciel
s'assombrit
les investisseurs attirés par le fort
ensoleillement de l'espagne affluent
conséquence la capacité de production
d'électricité et neuf fois supérieure
aux prévisions incapable de payer l'état
réduit les aides promises l'an gérard ou
la promo du carrefour nous avons reçu un
message du gouvernement nous disons
qu'il allait cesser de nous payer qu'ils
allaient nous expulser du système de
primes vous ne pouvez pas imaginer que
le président de votre propre pays va
vous ruiner
ce projet était pourtant le rêve de
toute une famille
stafford ça c'est la photo de papa avec
josé c'était le début les plaques venait
d'être monté sur mon profil
ensemble ils ont investi toutes leurs
économies avec la baisse des aides
impossible de rembourser leurs prêts ils
ont failli perdre leur maison familiale
voir que du jour au lendemain on peut
perdre une maison vieille de 200 ans ça
c'est difficile
la partie économique oui c'est important
mais l'humiliation personnel c'est
encore pire être traité comme un
délinquant c'est ça qui rend malade
pour s'en sortir
césar se rend chaque jour depuis six
mois devant le congrès des députés à
madrid
de 8h à 14h il reste debout pour
demander justice
salut alors la lutte continue et oui
toujours soit ils me trouvent une
solution soit il faudra me faire partir
d'ici avec une ambulance je bougerai pas
j'ai rien à perdre il y a deux ans césar
pensait toucher au but après deux grèves
de la faim et plusieurs sitting le
gouvernement de pedro sanchez avait
promis de l'aider finalement rien
le parti socialiste n'a envoyé une
lettre ils ont promis qu'ils allaient
m'aider moi et toutes les familles qui
sont dans cette situation
mais c'était un tissu de mensonges
si le cas de césar est l'un des plus
dramatiques d'espagne d'autres familles
disent avoir été trompé elles sont 60
2000 au total 5000 d'entre elles sont
regroupées dans cette association
comme césar ces patriotes ont cru
s'offrir le soleil tout en aidant leurs
pays l'espagne alors si pressés
d'atteindre les objectifs de l'ue en
matière de transition écologique c'est
le document du gouvernement 2007
appelant les citoyens espagnols à
investir il disait le soleil peut être à
toi ils n'ont pas respecté leurs
promesses ils nous ont juste fait payer
ses installations
absence d'anticipation mauvais calcul
cette famille dénonce un manque de
régulation et l'improvisation de l'état
le gouvernement nous a dit allez-y
continuer à investir alors qu'il aurait
pu limiter le nombre d'investisseurs et
d'hier sens et c'est tout ce que l'on
demande c'est que de ses 30 à 50% contre
les a supprimées nous qu'on pense à
hauteur de 20 à 25%
[Musique]
sollicité le parti socialiste espagnol
n'a pas répondu à nos questions la
droite qui avait également couper dans
les aides des pauses désormais un
amendement peut-être clé pour ces
familles
le but de cet amendement c'est de
permettre aux familles qui ont construit
ces installations de toucher la prime
qui leur avaient été promises la
boire au conseil en financement que ce
député souhaite tirer du futur fonds
national pour l'électricité durable
nouveau mode de financement des énergies
renouvelables
nous pensons que ce fonds est bien il
doit être modifié pour permettre aux
petits producteurs photovoltaïques
d'être dédommagés
pour l'heure la date du vote reste très
incertaine de même que son résultat